but first we really are reaching crunch
time for brexit this week the government
put forward proposals to the European
Union for a revised deal now they
weren't dismissed out of hand but the
response in Brussels was lukewarm at
best Boris Johnson has once again
claimed that we will leave the EU on the
31st of October Deal or No Deal but how
exactly does he plan to make that happen
well let's see if our first guest has
the answers the Housing and local
government secretary robert genrich's
thank you very much for being with us hi
good morning this morning now I am keen
to get on to brexit and to try and
answer some of those questions I know
many of our viewers will have but I just
want to start on a story that Sky News
has really been focusing on in the last
few days and that's about the death of a
19 year old boy Harry Don killed in a
road accident in August and the suspect
is the wife of a diplomat who has left
to the United States claiming diplomatic
immunity what is the government doing
about this
well I'm very sorry and this is a very
tragic incident the Foreign Secretary
has spoken to the American ambassador
and made clear our disappointment that
the woman involved in this incident has
left the UK using diplomatic immunity
cases of diplomatic immunity do come up
from time to time they are difficult but
the family involved have our absolute
assurance that we're going to do
everything we can to resolve this we
want the police to be able to continue
their inquiries and for whatever actions
they deem fit to be able to take place
and for justice to be done you say that
cases of diplomatic immunity come up but
I mean this is a death it's not you know
a few of ordered speeding tickets it's
pretty serious this is a very more
serious so quiet this is a very serious
situation my heart goes out to this
family who now want answers and what
justice what I can say is that the local
MP who is Andrea leads and the business
secretary has met the family the Foreign
Secretary has offered to meet the family
will do so shortly and he couldn't have
been clearer when he spoke to the
American ambassador that we are very
disappointed by the way events have
turned out and we want to see the u.s.
changed their mind and this lady come
back to the UK to answer the questions
that she needs to
thank you and well we'll certainly be
pursuing that story and in there kind of
coming days and weeks and I'm keen to
talk to you about brexit as well are we
gonna leave on the 31st of October
absolutely I mean the promise that
couldn't have been clearer as you said
in your introduction all along that this
government wants to get brexit done we
want to leave on the on the 31st of
October and we will be doing everything
in our power to bring that about
so if there isn't a deal agreed by the
19th of October which let's get real is
definitely a possibility will the Prime
Minister be writing a letter requesting
an extension to brexit well we've said
that as any government would do we will
comply with the law however all of ours
really specific what all of our efforts
now are focused on trying to get a deal
and we've just put forward some I think
very reasonable and thoughtful proposals
to the EU they try to answer the
questions that had dogged the previous
deal prepared by Theresa May they say
that for the legitimate concerns of the
Irish government that we will create a
new arrangement on the island of Ireland
which will enable goods to flow freely
there won't be any hard infrastructure
at the border and we will remove the
backstop and replace it with something
much more democratic which is a consent
mechanism so the people of Northern
Ireland can always have an ultimate say
over where they want these arrangements
to continue I hope that the EU will now
engage with these proposals and that we
can leave the EU in a very orderly and
amicable way on the 31st of October but
I don't think with greatest respect
there's much point in speculating or
what might happen
should the eve fail to come forward and
engage with our proposals okay I know
that you want this deal to get over the
line but just you have to bear with me
for a minute because if you just look at
what the EU been saying we have to at
least entertain the possibility that
this is not going to happen I mean you
know they've called for fundamental
changes Leah Veronica says they fall
short in a number of aspects Donald Tusk
says that EU is not convinced I mean you
can see why people are getting a bit
twitchy here so I'll just go back to my
question if a deal isn't agreed will the
Prime Minister pen that letter
requesting an extension well the promise
has been very clear that he is not going
to extend
50 so I don't think he personally could
have been any clearer we have said that
we will comply with the law however what
we're going to do now is work as hard as
we possibly can to secure that deal and
I know there are mixed messages coming
out of the EU that always are this is a
negotiation you would expect there to be
some noises off around the margins
however the reaction to this deal has
actually been surprisingly positive if
you look at the domestic reaction you've
seen support from the DPA you one would
hope would like to come to the table and
ensure that we can leave in orderly
fashion their criticisms in the past
have been that we don't have a deal
that's able to get it through the House
of Commons
I think the PM has been able to
demonstrate that this deal has a good
chance of doing that it's not just
conservatives and DP members actually
there's a number of Labour MPs who do
respect the outcome of the referendum
who said that they're inclined to
support this arrangement we hope that
the EU will now productively engage in a
discussion and that these can be the
basis of a way forward you see I'm still
trying to work out what is gonna happen
because we're now in October
I mean it's crunch time right and I have
to say I am really a little bit confused
because you're saying that no matter
what happens you're not going to extend
you're going to leave deal or no deal at
the end of October you're also saying as
you have consistently that the
government is going to comply with the
law but the law according to the ban Act
says that if there isn't a deal then
there must be an extension I mean I
don't understand this you're a clever
man come on what's going on here these
well let's look through let's work
through what could happen in the coming
days we've published these proposals I
think as I said they're good proposals
and they do finally point us to a way
forwards the EU now need to engage with
those I think it would be extremely
disappointing if the EU chose to walk
away and not engage with proposals where
we've made compromise and we know that
there is a high degree of support here
what's gonna happen in a couple of weeks
time if the EU doesn't agree that's fair
enough well if you want a good outcome I
don't think there's much to be gained in
speculate
on what we may or may not do what
tactics we might choose to deploy later
on in the negotiation but we have been
clear that if we can't get a deal
through the House of Commons or if which
seems you know concerning at the moment
that the EU might not choose to engage
with I hope that's not the case then
this government has no intention of
extending article 50 we think the UK
needs to move forward so you've just
seen at the Conservative Party
conference the policies we're putting
forward for the future like investing in
the NHS and schools in extra police
officers in my own area in housing the
whole country really is crying out for
us to get brexit done and to move
forwards and that's what we're trying to
do now so there is a moment here where
the EU need to match our compromise with
a willingness to negotiate and they
would be quite wrong if they think that
by rejecting these proposals we would
change tack offer something materially
different to what we're putting forward
here we've put forward something that
does represent a very significant
compromise we want them to engage in
turn can you rule out asking any other
country to veto an extension I've not
heard any serious talk of that beyond
the speculation that I've seen in the
papers so I think that's with with all
due respect just tittle-tattle okay so I
just wondered like just listening to you
is a real truth that the government is
prepared to extend but you just need to
show that you're dragged there kicking
and screaming that you don't want to do
it that it's those pesky remains to
force you into it
so that you can go to the election and
hopefully win a majority off the back of
that is that the real truth here no well
you're right in one sense which is that
Boris Johnson and this government will
do absolutely everything in our power to
deliver brexit on the 31st to October
but we have no plan as to what might
happen if Parliament you know doesn't
allow us to get brexit yeah on the 31st
of October because we intend to get it
done on that date and that's the sole
focus of this government at the moment
we don't want to see this go on beyond
that date I don't think the country does
either people
really want us now to get Briggs it down
and I think there is a genuine
opportunity now to do that if the EU can
respond to the compromises that we've
made and offer some in return and if you
look at the proposal that we've put
forward you know this is a very fair
proposal okay
I'm keen not to get into the details of
the proposals we've done so much on the
kind of intricacies of the brexit deals
and just very quickly is the government
visiting the Queen this weekend to try
and ask for another progression of
parliament ahead of a potential Queen
speech I I don't know the details of
when the next Privy Council meeting is
going to be held but we've clearly set
out our intention to promote Parliament
in the usual way later this coming week
to have a Queen's speech and we're not
taking any more days than is absolutely
necessary to do that the way that a
Queen's speech happens you know requires
changes to the security arrangements in
Parliament for the Queen and the royal
household to make certain arrangements
and so we're simply pouring upon for the
minimum amount of time to enable that to
happen is it acceptable though to ask
for Queen's Speech when you want an
election because if you can have an
election there's gonna be no time to
implement the program you're effectively
just using the Manik to read out a party
political broadcast no it's perfectly
normal when you have a new prime
minister a new administration for us to
be able to set out our proposals and our
legislative agenda in a Queen's speech
that's always happens in these
circumstances you're right we want a
general election we've been trying to
get a general election now for for some
time and absolutely without precedent
the Labour Party is the Official
Opposition who have been turning us down
every occasion but you know until such
time as they come forward and agree to
that election to submit themselves to
the Democratic will of the people
Parliament needs to continue this is the
longest session of Parliament for
hundreds of years so it's perfectly
reasonable now to have a Queen's speech
and bring forward a new agenda and I'm
keen to talk at your brief housing
something that is really important
perhaps a number one issue to many of
our viewers and people in the country do
you think house prices need to come down
well there's definitely an issue of an
affordability in this
entry there are yes millions of young
people who can't get on the housing
ladder I mean I view this primarily as a
supply problem we haven't been building
enough homes of all ten years but that
means that prices would come down right
if you increase its supply well well I
want to ensure that more homes are built
for all people in all stages of their
lives and by doing that we will make
homes more affordable so we're investing
in affordable homes through an
affordable homes program with investing
nine billion pounds in that we're
ensuring that councils have the powers
to borrow should they want to build more
Council houses and encouraging councils
to do that and in my time in office only
ten weeks or so I've also been bringing
forward planning reforms so we can
unlock more land and ensure that private
developers can finally build more homes
and people can expand their homes as
they need to as their families get
larger as elderly relatives come to live
with them it's only by doing that though
in the long term will sustainably fix
this problem it does feel like it's one
of the key dividing issues in our
society a minute I mean Boris Johnson
made a very passionate defense of
capitalism in his conference speech I
just wondered that for so many young
people who made the dream of owning
their home is effectively a fantasy why
should they believe in capitalism if
they haven't even got the hope of
getting any capital themselves well I
think you're absolutely right I mean
this is why housing matters it's not
just about four walls and a roof it's
much more than that is about having a
stake in society saving for the future
investing in your family putting down
roots in a community and there's all the
reasons why as conservatives we've
always believed in homeownership that
dream has become unobtainable for many
young people you know of my generation
and the concept has fought partly I mean
you've been in government for quite a
long time now well we've done a number
of things to get more homes built in
fact last year we built more homes in
this country than any year bar one in my
adult lifetime this year it looks like
it'll be significantly better than that
but there is a lot more that we need to
do what I'm doing is refocusing on
homeownership because although this has
become unobtainable to some I still
believe that the vast majority of young
people want
to own a home certainly that's my
experience of young people that I know
so we want more policies like shared
ownership for example that can help
people to get a deposit get on the
ladder more affordably we want to bring
forward planning reform so the system is
simpler and cheaper one planning reform
that we've announced recently is the
ability to build upwards in your home if
your family grows so you can affordably
create more space in your property and
I'm also going to focus again on quality
because there have been concerns about
the quality of some homes they've been
built in this country and I want to
build confidence in new housing so that
communities can welcome new housing
developed by ensuring that they look
good they're environmentally friendly
and people really see these as a benefit
to their local community and I'm
interested to know your thoughts on
something the transfer said in a recent
interview he was asked about inheritance
tax and this is what
Sajid Javid said I understand the
arguments against that tax I do think
that when people have paid taxes already
there is a real issue with then asking
them on that income to pay taxes all
over again it's something that's on my
mind
do you think inheritance tax needs to be
reformed well I think we're gonna have
to leave that for the Chancellor to make
up nice I've been a Treasury Minister I
know that you know you don't comment on
what may or may not happen in budget it
is a tax which is particularly unpopular
because people can see the fundamental
unfairness of paying tax twice and
people having to you know leave property
which they've saved up their whole lives
to build up to their their children and
grandchildren and see them pay
additional tax so it's always been
attacks which has been perceived to be
unfair and of course many of those on
higher incomes will find financial
arrangements to ensure they don't pay so
I can see why the Chancellor is
interested in this one
now I'm going out of time but I'm going
to squeeze in one more anyway and now
you've got a pretty big important job
but frankly most of our viewers may not
recognize you you're relatively new
addition to the cabinet table so what's
an interesting thing that we should all
know about Robert jungbaek Oh blimey
well I mean I think I'm the youngest
cabinet minister since William hay
join the cabinet the first Millennials
I'm the firstborn in the 1980s and if we
do manage to get a general election
later on this also when they'll be the
first minister to been elected four
times in five years assuming that my
voters back home in Newark do vote for
me again so I like to think I'm the most
accountable Member of Parliament at the
moment
Foca PR on to that thank you Robert Jen
Rick thank you for being on the program